donc on à nicolas lhenry qui vient de
nous rejoindre en plateau bonsoir alors
c'est la deuxième force politique dans
le département des yvelines qui ressort
de ce scrutin la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale sera
présente donc elle dans onze
circonscriptions sur 12 ce sera donc au
second tour des élections législatives
2022 et oui justin est en fait c'est la
conséquence des résultats du premier
tour des élections législatives vous
savez un la gauche et parti uni dans ce
scrutin eh bien on va regarder tout de
suite les détails des résultats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'un des deux candidats de la
haine du ps arrivé en tête au premier
tour des élections législatives
willem martin a obtenu 32% des suffrages
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
il devance la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle
aurélie pièce enza avec 25% des voix
nous sommes donc largement en tête nous
sommes même en tête dans quatre villes
sur sept dans l'ensemble de la de la
circonscription avec d'excellents scores
à trappes à la verrière et même à
elancourt autres territoires où la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale et devant la majorité
présidentielle la 8e circonscription
benjamin lucas a récolté 33 % des
exprimés contre 24% des suffrages pour
edwige hervieux candidate du mouvement
ensemble il ya aujourd'hui une volonté
de faire barrage emmanuel macron de ne
pas subir une politique injuste et
brutal fatah 65 ans la baisse continue
du pouvoir d'achat le prix augmenter les
salaires qui stagnent et puis de
l'espoir parce que nous portons un
projet de justice sociale un projet pour
le pouvoir d'achat pour la dignité pour
le respect des citoyennes et des
citoyens avec l'union de ces mouvements
de la france un soumise au parti
socialiste en passant par le parti
communiste ou encore europe ecologie les
verts la gauche signe son retour dans
les yvelines sur les douze
circonscriptions aux candidats de la
nuque ps sont au second tour en annoncer
la gauche ya à peine six mois comme
morte et en fait nous voilà au second
tour dans cinq circonscriptions y
compris la nôtre ici avec un score qui
est dans la moyenne nationale dans les
25 % on connaît la sociologie de notre
circonscription sait que ça va être
difficile vu justement cette sociologie
là mais si tout les abstentionnistes et
bien vont voter pour nous on peut a
remporté cette circonscription en
relativisant par rapport à la
participation la gauche redevient une
force politique de premier plan sur le
territoire yvelinois en 2017 aucun
candidat de gauche n'avait réussi à
accéder au second tour des élections
législatives
on vient de le voir dans votre sujet de
circonscription roncq ont vu l année
parce arrivé en tête la 8e et la 11e
circonscription lé duel entre les
candidats de ces territoires risque
d'être serré effectivement justine et on
l'a vu dans la 11e circonscription des
yvelines williams martinez est en
ballottage favorable le candidat de
l'ani ps obtient deux mille voix de plus
qu aurélie pias elsa face à la candidate
de la majorité présidentielle la gauche
a de la vence mais attention au report
des voix vous le savez les républicains
pourrait lui être favorable la clé un
pour la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale finalement ce sera
la participation et on écoute williams
martinez au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude et de julien leroy la jeunesse
les quartiers populaires est en fait
toutes celles et tous ceux qui veulent
tourner la page d' emmanuel macron se
sont mobilisés massivement donc bonne
nouvelle pour le premier tour mais
soyons très clairs pour le second tour
il faut passer un cap supplémentaire
tous ceux qui se sentaient pas encore
concernés par cette élection maintenant
qu'ils vont pouvoir choisir entre
emmanuel macron ou la nouvelle union
populaire maintenant il faut qu'ils se
déplacent il faut qu'ils fassent le
choix alors la 11e circonscription c'est
cette commune parmi ces communes il y
attrape et williams martinez a réalisé
son plus gros score sur la
circonscription récoltons plus de 55%
des voix et il ya un potentiel électoral
c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui se sont pas déplacés à trappes
l'abstention atteint près de 63% et
qu'en est il donc concernant la 8e
circonscription et ben c'est la même
situation dans la 8e circonscription
benjamins lucas candidats de la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale a
récolté près de trois mille électeurs de
plus que la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle comme dans la 11e
circonscription tout dépendra du report
des voix notamment des électeurs du
rassemblement national arrivé en
troisième position et des républicains
arrivé en quatrième position et le
candidat de la nuit parce qu'on aussi
aller les convaincre ses électeurs de la
droite on écoute benjamins lucas c'est
évidemment les abstentionnistes mais je
le dis aussi à celles et ceux qui ont
fait d'autres choix moi je ferai en
sorte de travailler avec tout le monde y
compris avec ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord avec moi la question c'est est
ce qu'on a besoin d'un député aux ordres
de macron bresse qu'on a besoin d'un
député libre et qu'il descend ce
territoire et cette circonscription est
ce que veulent ses habitants pour le
pouvoir d'achat les services publics
c'est ça le sujet et la question c'est
aussi un référendum sur la retraite à 65
ans donc on aura des surprises moi je
vous le dis je pense qu'elles les
électrices et les électeurs que que vous
classé à droite mais qui refusent la
politique d' emmanuel macron et pour
conclure nicolas une autre
circonscription risquent elles d'être
serrée également oui ça va être serré
notamment dans la 7e circonscription
territoire ou nadia et ancien ministre
délégué à la ville est candidate à l'âme
pour la majorité présidentielle
elle sera opposée à la représentante de
la nu ps michel christophoul et il faut
savoir qu'ici là c'était très serré au
premier tour il y avait mille voix
d'écart entre les deux candidates mais
c'est nadia qui était en tête alors pour
conclure finalement par rapport à ces
duels on l'a vu on a l'impression que ce
sera la participation qui sera décisive
alors du coup raphaël mata duvignau
est-ce que vous pensez que ces candidats
justement de la nu peuvent passer au
second tour notamment s'ils arrivent à
mobiliser les abstentionnistes de leur
territoire
oui alors effectivement vous avez
parfaitement raison la clé du scrutin en
plus qu'à pour les circonscriptions dont
on a parlé
seront à la fois la participation est
donc le taux d'abstention donc la
capacité de nuxe uni baisse à mobiliser
les abstentionnistes ça c'est un élément
important et j'ai envie de dire je ne
suis pas un tueur à ce que n'ont pas
réussi à mobiliser au premier tour pour
quelles raisons ils arriveraient à
mobiliser au second tour donc je là je
suis assez sceptique un autre élément
aussi n'y a pas en considération c'est
le haut il en parle partout qu'on en
parle partout c'est la réserve de bois
est ce que est ce que les candidats
soutenus par le par la nuit baisse
aucune réserve de voix ce n'est pas sûr
quand on voit les autres les autres
partis d autres chiffres des niveaux des
circonscriptions on voit que la réserve
de voix est assez faible
donc ça c'est un élément aussi à prendre
en considération est a contrario quand
on regarde les chiffres de les chiffres
de mort tremble on voit que bon les
électeurs républicains on peut supposer
je n'en sais rien mais on peut supposer
qu'elle appelait les électeurs
républicains iront probablement se
reporter sur un candidat de la majorité
présidentielle
donc en fait mécaniquement il est
possible que un candidat de la majorité
présentielle nice passé devant
simplement avec le réseau avec la
réserve de voix donc ça c'est un point
important est un autre point important
c'est le comportement des électeurs du
rassemblement national parce que j'ai
oublié de le dire tout à l'heure mais
malgré tout au niveau national ces
électeurs-là représente depuis
maintenant un certain nombre d'années en
réalité s'est stabilisé entre 18 et 20%
et donc il faut compter avec notre force
là et les électeurs qui n'ont pas de
candidat finalement qualifié de bon tour
que vont ils faire et ce qu'ils vont
voter du ps où est ce qu'ils vont voter
pour un candidat soutenu par emmanuel
macron je n'en sais rien c'est assez
c'est assez volatile ce sera bonne at il
eu vent de la vie donc voilà c'est cissé
unis cinar à prédire mais voilà la
question c'est vraiment la réserve de
voix pour le candidat du ps il a bien
dit
merci beaucoup nicolas landry d'avoir
été avec nous en plateau journalistes
pour tv 78